this show is sponsored by betterhelp if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
betterhelp a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
help.com trash Tuesday whether you're
new to cannabis or an Old Pro there's no
denying that many of the products on the
market seem iffy at best and when you
want to relax if he is the last way you
want to feel ready for a good time
without the guesswork order your THC
products for mood today for 20 off your
first order and free gummies go to
hellomood.com and use promo code trash
Tuesday that's hello
m-o-o-d.com promo code trash Tuesday for
20 off your order and free gummies thank
you to our sponsor ZocDoc ZocDoc is the
only free app that lets you find and
book doctors who are patient reviewed
take your insurance are available when
you need them and treat almost every
condition Under the Sun go to zocdoc.com
trash and download the ZocDoc app for
free then find and book a top rated
doctor today many are available within
24 hours that's
zocdoc.com
trash zocdoc.com trash hi slugs I'm
doing stand-up comedy and I will be in
Miami Boston New York and a bunch of
other places you can get tickets at
Esther onice.com yo what up sluggies I'm
gonna be in Canada and Toronto this
month April 21st and 22nd I will be in
Raleigh North Carolina May 12th and 13th
and Salt Lake City in June Calgary in
August I have a lot of other dates we're
adding so go to annieleterman.com shows
and then every Thursday you can get
another dose of me on my solo podcast
Annie wood can't wait to see you there
hey sluggies it's Nikki Glazer
um I would love to meet you at one of my
shows I have meet and greets and you can
just come to my show come see my live
stand-up show I'm on tour right now the
good girl troller you can check out all
the tour dates at nikkiglazer.com but
upcoming dates that I'd really like to
see you at because ticket sales are not
cranking is Ithaca uh Greenboro Durham
and some go look at the thing and you'll
see
this is why people don't go to my shows
because I don't know where I am but I
have so many dates coming up and I
really hope to see you there thanks I
got like a whole package from so this
company bought juicy and Reebok so they
sent me a bunch of stuff and I decided
to this was a good episode to wear it oh
for sure Delilah will be left out but
did she even live in this country well
we're even here [__] I think she was
but she wasn't like fully Americanized
no but she was very latinized oh true
wait show Nikki your shirt wait let me
see remember
no I think it started it was Julia
Roberts because Julia Roberts was dating
her the camera guy and he was she was
and she was not giving him a divorce she
wouldn't sign the divorce papers so then
she wore dump me and then they turned it
in or dump him and then they turned it
into like a meme show it was like one of
the OG memes she wore another shirt too
that was like her name on it that was
like
Fu so that maybe not that aggressive but
it had the girl's name on it that's so
crazy
it's so mean like you're getting the man
also you're a movie star like I feel
like you have when you have that high of
a status or the most beautiful famous
movie star you gotta be careful when
you're punching down right but there was
an opening down then that's all that
happened it was in the 90s and so I
wouldn't like now I think it would get a
lot of attention and people would maybe
pile on but I think it's like we we only
know about it because like certain meme
accounts will like bring it back right
it was like an underground artist no I
remember it because she had armpit hair
too remember yes and sweaty pants it was
actually that was accidental it was she
was like she forgot I think
but who forgot remember Sharon Stone
wore a Gap t-shirt to the Oscars one
year these are just moments that all
kind of like Cloud together for me yeah
I just got like a horny for that I know
[Music]
I just want to acknowledge How brave I
am to be in a room with two pretty tall
blondes right now like that's you guys
have a different life than me it's just
different for you I was thinking of
dying hit my hair brown recently and I
and I and then I go no I can't because I
I will feel the shift because I don't
know it but I know we get something from
life that I can't perceive and I can't
really put my finger on but I'm get
we're getting something extra but when
you get attention as a hot brunette like
you're really oh then your face is
breaking it like oh yeah yeah Esther's
just got starting to get her hot
attention
you are it's like you've been by Mitzvah
honestly I think oh that's so nice by
the way I saw your man last night I know
he came home and it was the first thing
he was like I love Esther I love him he
was like their love for you came through
to me he was like some people can be
like they can know they can meet him
without me even know me and not be as
nice to like they were like it was just
like he was like they just accepted me
as if it was you and it was so nice he
was like producing this major event and
he was so good at his job like he's so
good at what he does it was such a like
yeah it was just cool to see like he is
really good at producing yeah because
there's a whole other stuff like your
life yes honestly he totally does yeah
he really like he thinks about things in
just a different way of like um just he
thinks about the future every like he
talks that he uses the word intentional
a lot but to be intentional about things
but it gets in the way a little bit when
I like for instance I have to like make
videos coming up of being like
Greensboro come see me Ithaca like and
and the promoters are asking for them I
hate making those videos so much you're
good at them you just get them done like
no I don't I suffer I want them to be
really funny
you like set things on fire yeah
it's got to be like pop fast because I
will like drag it on yeah all those
people won't even wait for the joke I'm
like oh my god I think I'm just saying
because you can see in the algorithm
like if they're well I can just tell
that it didn't like there wasn't
retention so it didn't go there's no
there's no retention you got to do it in
the first like three seconds yeah it's
it's so it's brutal and I watch other
comedians do it and I said what is the
best way to do these shout out videos
and there's no good way it's all
confidence in the face like come see us
and do they work like I want to pull an
audience one day and be like how did you
guys find out about the show I want to
know what is actually working yeah I
just did a Morning Show today for um
Lexington Kentucky I forgot about it so
I like got out of like I had sleep Mass
marks on my face and I like rushed to
the zoom and I'm just like I do this
whole interview and then um and then
they write me and they're like we forgot
to record and I go I'm not doing
anything I'd rather just because I don't
know that people watching morning
you'll see the views too when they put
it online and it's like 41 if it's like
a big hit you know yes what is this do
you guys ever when you if you like meet
someone that's like a fan of yours on
the street like my instinct is always to
instantly conduct market research yeah
like where do you know me from how do
you know any like what well that back
part that's why I don't do it I was on a
date I was on a date with a guy once and
we have to bleep so much of this I was
on a date with a guy once at the mall
and a guy at Burlington I was like oh my
God you're Annie Letterman the comedian
and I was like oh my God I thought he
was gonna list my credits in front of
this guy was like a first date oh my God
I'm gonna list my credits and he goes oh
you called me at the ice house oh my God
what have you asked and it didn't it was
just they'll they'll say they I don't I
don't want to hear any feedback ever
that's my point like I just kind of like
went through like why do I not want to
hear but I don't want to hear any
feedback ever ever don't like me I don't
want anything that is really not to give
you the feedback yeah
then you'll be you'll be okay you'll be
leading from what you like and what you
think is good yeah right instead of what
because I think I everything bounces off
because the algorithm got me all like
messed up and twisted around and then
like no I watched Bert's videos and I'm
like he's so interactive he goes into a
town he like engages the town's people
he meets
I know I'm like I've gotta get back on
what where is he no because yeah we if
we go out drinking like I don't want to
be dramatic but I I like hung out with
Bert on the road and seen what happens
like he's getting chased on the street
he's topless if we're topless drinking
tomorrow we're getting raped okay right
it's just getting fans that want them to
like sign their butt cheeks but that's
exhausting I mean he must in the quiet
of the night alone have uh he's not
alone he's on the absorb us with us
you're right he's that's another thing
if you I constantly keep people around
too because I never want to be alone
with my thoughts but I think that that's
what he does but he's just a marketing
master and he's hilarious like I'm not
taking anything away from his talent and
like how really is now he connects to
people and how people just like love him
but there are some people you watch that
are marketing Geniuses and I know I know
that there are tricks to like like even
hashtags like when I post a video and
have to like hashtag stand up comedy I
wanna [__] don't die you have to
though pay someone else to do it you
can't those moments are too they teach
for me there is a a monetary like
there's a way you can pay someone else
to do that humiliating part just so you
don't have to I know but then I don't
trust them to put up the clip that's
gonna be good and like I just don't I I
it's just Nikki I've seen some sometimes
like Gander into people's hashtags and
it'll be like hashtag poverty hashtag
like they'll be doing something hashtag
I always say that okay so I it's gonna
be forever but I always say no it's cute
I like it I'm gonna hashtag kill myself
if we keep talking about hashtag oh why
do you want to talk about but that's
what you should learn something really
important from yeah I actually do have a
question for you or basically there's
something that you said a while ago that
I recently relate to and it's kind of
blowing my mind because I never thought
I would but I remember you I don't know
if it's your on your podcast or whatever
but like you are not comfortable getting
compliments about your like physical
appearance and I was always always like
how is that even humanly possible and I
think recently to get compliments yeah
okay that was my first thought to be
fair
um but like recently I'm working on not
needing validation and reassurance and I
feel like I must have some progress
because when people compliment my body
I'm like
it is weird though but do you feel the
same way from girls and guys is it
different I do feel the same way
actually which is even more which is
also surprising do you still yeah and my
my thing is that I I can take it in and
I can go yeah you're right like it does
or my thing is always people are like
your legs or your your like last
yesterday I like took off my shirt and
some guy was like someone works out and
I go I don't I have my dad's arms I just
got lucky like it makes me realize most
things you have are because you bought
like you're either Rich if you're hot
like you're hot or you're just your
dad's jeans are good or you're not like
my dad came in my mom that's why I have
good legs it's not some it's not Pilates
it's nothing there's nothing I I could
do something extra to make it better but
most of it it says arms too
the reason that I don't have good legs
is because my dad yes my mom well
exactly we have the same origin story
but it's like I also feel like when you
get compliments about your looks it's
just it reinforces that that's important
and that when now okay someone goes oh
my God you look so pretty today when I
don't look pretty do you not like me
then so you I don't hear nothing and
then it's like I always worry about it's
I don't want my worth to be about my
looks even though I'm desperate for that
as well yeah it's so weird like yeah
we're also in this business not that
everyone doesn't like suffer with these
things but I was thinking about to say
like we picked like the pits of hell
yeah the whole world is like the pits of
hell though yeah no but we literally are
on camera like we are like
yeah I I'm I'm wishing I'm trying to
like wean myself off of makeup and hair
and makeup because I did a show
yesterday it was like a just an
appearance on a reality show and I'm
showing up as myself but I'm like the
girls in the show are like stunning I'm
not gonna say what it is but I I watched
the show for the first time and I go I
can't walk in there doing my own hair
makeup like I gotta hire a team it's a
thousand dollars at least for hair
makeup because you have to go through
people's agents and like they pack on
prices yeah of course and then to get
styled for something where you that's
another 2500 if you want to like not
because I don't have naturally like good
style as when people are like wow you
have great style it's always because
these two girls Danny and Emma is that
true though today no but this is this is
a mess this is great style maybe we like
your regular style more because I like
my own someone was like I have this
friend if you ever need her to hire to
like make your house cute and I was like
oh that I wouldn't like either I want my
own ideas place I agree you want someone
to style your house yeah because I have
no I don't have any skill I don't know
how to buy a couch organize oh my gosh
all of it I just buy my friends couches
I go I've bought two of my friends
couches
no just like which one is it and like I
do that with everything like I don't
understand I get insulted that more girl
girls don't go like oh where's your
purse from I want to get that because
every time I see something cute I ask
where they got it and if I can get it
and like like because that's how I shop
it's like sometimes I want them to find
it on their own though just like to go
through the effort yeah like sometimes
I'm like I'm not gonna like give you the
no I I get that one time a girl I was
like on a plane I go your sweatshirt's
so cute it was just like this baggy like
cute sweater I go where'd you get it she
goes Vegas I'm like well we're not
getting more specific but like like it
was Italy or something I know but I do
get that about like you have to go find
it but it's fun to give people like a
little challenge yeah I don't know you
don't you give them hints they can ask
you questions back I recently liked a
friend's perfume and then oh I don't
know gatekeeper oh yeah yeah I've heard
about that really mad at me when I stole
their their scents to the point where
she was just basically like so skirting
around it and just like the it's a it's
in a blue bottle I was like is it this
like that makes me feel like we're not
living in a shared Community tribe and
like I'm exiled from yeah
I find myself doing that sometimes with
things where I'm like I found like some
kind of Beauty secret and I'm like I
don't want to tell my friends who are
already too pretty
you already have an advantage you have a
head start yeah I I really I will
withhold it and I have to stop myself
from doing it because I know that's such
an ugly thing to be like no it's just
for me but but is it a boundary though
maybe maybe it's a boundary true no it's
a it's definitely being like I don't
want her to be prettier okay
it feels so unnatural because I'm not a
gatekeeper but I only do it when I feel
like other people gatekeep with me and
then I'm like do I just leave the gates
unlocked too much and then I'm like
should I try gatekeeping with them and
it never feels right don't change who
you are for that because like it's I
don't know maybe I've just like done
mushrooms recently me too this morning
you did micro dose baby oh my God I need
to I need someone you might like it
because it's helping with you have ADD
yes and depression
and depression depression is [__] me
up lately it's like four out of seven
days I wake up and I'm just like but you
don't want to get my balcony like do you
know how I don't looks like a nice is
that high enough yeah exactly don't do
that [__] I will never jump I mean
that's like I'll be dragging yourself on
a skateboard that means that is so
humility humiliating be like twitching
on the sidewalk
I'm so sorry
no my dad once when he was yelling at me
my brother he was like I tell you guys
to to run into traffic but with my luck
you'd live and I just have to scoot you
around for the rest of my life it was
good wait I want to talk about the
depression thing because I feel like I'm
too high on mushrooms to get to it's so
weird that you think of high on
mushrooms right
no you think I'm high right doesn't it
suck when someone thinks you're high
yeah I feel it never happens to me oh my
God I hate people sometimes nail it for
me and I'm like oh God doesn't seem like
that I don't mean that with her though
because I feel like I don't know I get
what you're saying what am I giving that
makes you a very like calm yes Vibe I
told you why it's because I got here and
Pete was really like just like talking
to a normal person
um and I also feel at peace and with two
hot blondes wait okay the depression
thing yeah
um what do you do on those days because
I feel like I'm dealing with some
something similar I very much more an
anxiety girl than depression but when
those lows come through I'm like oh this
is so much harder like what's what do
you do I I get I get really
um I start saying really weird [__] to
like almost to get attention like to get
my friends like all my girls chat like I
have a chat with like seven of my best
friends and I start saying like dark
stuff because I know that they won't are
they Comics no you can't do the comics
it will not help no they want exactly
what I mean they're they're all just my
girlfriends and they know me so well and
I've been like this since high school
saying really dark things of like I want
to die or I'm gonna do and they I know
they're not gonna call anyone like it's
like a suicide hotline before I'm
actually because I'm I know that I'm so
sad girl alive
not too hot they don't know my secret
but they uh they don't smell good I'll
tell you that I just know that they I
just know that they have separate chats
going on about my mental health
sometimes of like uh-oh should we like
intervene because I just get really I
feel like I um because I want people to
like know how I'm feeling I think that's
why people commit suicide a lot of times
is because you want people to understand
the pain that you're going how bad you
felt because you don't it's not like I I
can't call in depressed work like you
can but it's kind of like we we're like
if I had coveted and said guys I have
like coveted and had a cold or whatever
I could not show up today but if I'm
like I kind of want to like kill myself
today so I'm probably not gonna be good
on mic it just is a weird you can't even
call them my cramps but do you find that
if you don't cancel the thing that your
depression is wanting to you to cancel
are you better no I'm terrible no but
are you better after like oh I did it
does that at least make you feel it
because I I go like I I used to do a
podcast four days a week and it was
getting bad because it was just like one
out of those four was gonna be me in a
bad mood not being able to be funny
totally my office do you think you were
trying to hold yourself accountable in
that way like maybe keep yourself like
into why I show up because to do afford
um that was during I came up with that
plan during covid when no comedy was
happening and I was like okay that's
just my stage time then it's just you
know get those 10 000 hours of
broadcasting in right but um no I I get
real but I get to a point where I sing
really dark things that freak people out
because I'm just wanting attention I
want people to understand like I I'm not
just sad I wanna like I'm thinking about
thinking about killing myself is
soothing to me today and I want people I
want to like scare people so I can I
don't really want this but
subconsciously I want love I want
attention I want someone to go what's
going on and I want to [__] cry and I
can't cry crying is like coming to me I
need like tools I need like
another partner though I would be like
worried but yeah your friends are like
trained they are because they're used to
because I would be like go to the I
haven't done it yet or the cops are Dr
Drew somebody's getting called no and I
know and I'm like I know that so many
times I've wanted to like I've thought
I've been so suicidal and stuff and I've
never even gotten close to trying it and
know
that that thought like today I'm like
suicide why would you be suicide like
life is awesome I always know that on
the other side of it it's gonna get
better so I do know but I'm totally open
to like going to a place like Gary
Goldman went Neil I'm Neil Brennan like
I like these guys that talk about their
suicidal ideations because it makes me
feel like
okay I'm not alone like and you can go
to a hospital and just hang out they're
not gonna lock you away forever like
I've been in uh psych wards before do
you have like manic swings too like
where it's like you're like hyper hyper
hyper like yeah it's usually it's
sometimes after really big things like I
remember after I um the last one that
was a really bad episode of like it
lasted like a week was after I uh guest
hosted Kimmel and it just came on after
that because I think it was just such a
high and then afterwards it's just like
there's there's no more of that and the
anticipation everything but I think it's
it's I remember that set wasn't that
like uh yeah I like roasted politicians
and then wasn't didn't you do a joke
about female Pilots was that you ah I
did do a joke about human class but I
don't know if it was that one but yeah
um I'm really glad that you like I'm I'm
finding myself feeling grateful that
you're open about this stuff because I
especially with your outfit your goth
outfits I know you were really five and
I do not I'm not someone I don't
identify as suicidal at all however I do
like lately a lot have just the voice in
my head that's like I always notice I
say I'm like I want to die I want to die
like yeah as soon as something feels
cringy to me or like uncomfortable my
go-to is I wanted to I don't mean that I
don't feel it but I do think that the
fact that I'm even saying those words I
shouldn't that should not yeah be
happening it isn't like our in our
language right now it's like I'm dead
like for yes funny and stuff like it's
in our language a lot it's like but it
is is good right because yeah words have
meaning and like if you like you know
scream at a thing of a glass of water it
can like grow mold or you know what I'm
saying like people were like nice to
water yeah what's the bleep do you
remember that movie I think maybe that
was it wasn't it like the beginning of
Nexium too like that documentary isn't
it weird how like second episodes when
it gets weird it was like first couple
episodes like oh it's pretty cheap it's
all like based on psychology I'm always
like oh you're so good and then somebody
underneath the trauma a kid it's always
like some kid gets [__] and then
anyone cutting you off from your family
get the [__] out of that system like
that's
um but yeah but what really gets me out
of it is crying and it's so that is like
it's the simplest thing I can't do it
and I really fight it off when I'm
depressed because I just don't because I
almost when you're depressed you feel
like you're like seeing the world as it
is and you don't want to be anesthetized
to how [__] Bleak it is and you feel
like you it's almost like a manic thing
of like I'm Jesus like I know what's
what's up I I like you know when you see
people screaming you're like why don't
they just get help and it's like no
because they think they know yeah and
they think you're all dummy and that's
what I think when I'm depressed I'm like
anyone that's like oh
a dog or like ah like like that looks at
the world and wonder I'm just like
you're disgusting like you don't like
you don't know what's really up and
everything's [__] like I'm lucky that
I'm not living in [__] Sudan or
wherever like I acknowledge like I have
privilege and all that stuff and that I
shouldn't be depressed but I just feel
like I don't want to get out of it but
then I cry and then it freaks me about
how much I can go from being like I want
to kill myself like I'm checking myself
in somewhere to like crying for two
minutes and then I'm like
let's watch Last of Us like totally fine
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because
we're always growing and changing bro I
literally am a different person every
single day which is probably a problem
but that's why I need better help
because I need a therapist to help me
work through these things like I'm
always changing I always say I'm
literally embarrassed of everything I've
ever said and done until this moment
starting now therapy has really helped
me on my journey of self-discovery just
from like figuring out who am I what do
I really want what why am I struggling
so hard with discipline like all these
things and as you guys know like
discovering that my emotional needs were
not met when I was younger and I would
have never figured that out if I wasn't
using better help for therapy discover
your potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday there's
been quite a bit of history surrounding
most THC products today whether it's
like the dosage what's actually in them
how am I going to feel or like what's
even legal and whether you're new to
cannabis or an Old Pro there's no
denying that many of the products on the
market seem iffy at best and when you
want to relax if he is the last way you
want to feel like that's actually
unacceptable mood puts an end to
guessing games it's 100 federally legal
Delta H and Delta 9 THC you can have
shipped straight to you no doctors no
waiting just Affordable Legal THC and
for a limited time mood is giving our
listeners free Delta 9 gummies and 20
off your first order visit hellomood.com
and use our code trash Tuesday you guys
what I love about mood is how specific
they get with their strains and the
literal moods that they can help put you
in so for me I like to use a product
that's going to make me feel creative
they have that specific when I'm like oh
I just want pure sleepiness relaxation I
go for that maybe there's a party mode
option like I just really need it to be
specific and tailored I can't be playing
guessing games with strains I need a
brand that's going to tell me exactly
the mood that I'm going to get when I
take it mood offers federally legal
forms of THC extracted from hemp plants
and all of their products are regularly
third-party tested in drug enforcement
agency registered labs and they're
sourced from small farms and grown
organically the experts at mood have
tested and tailored different strains
for specific moods this is my favorite
thing about them energized for when you
want to seize the day creative to get
inspired and mentally stimulated focused
just perfect for getting in the zone for
me I love to combine that one with some
coffee and just get the work done that I
need to get done there's also euphoric
erotic sleepy chill social body Soother
I mean they all sound so good they're
making my mouth water are you ready for
a good time without the guesswork order
your THC products from mood today and
for 20 off your first order and free
gummies go to hellomood.com and use
promo code trash Tuesday that's hello
m-o-o-d.com promo code trash Tuesday for
20 off your order and free gummies
foreign
people definitely save crying for
Instagram I mean that is the next level
where I'm like that to me I would rather
have double penetration on camera than
crying no I would rather people see my
medical nudes which are when I'm
stretching
like medical news is so crying it's like
I will like if something happens and it
moves me to tears and that's on camera
I'm okay with it now because that means
that I like
something really got me there and I want
to like be able to express that however
I'm not gonna be in a moment of crying
that's not being captured and be like
let's capture that's what I'm talking
about I don't mind if like on my reality
show I think I cried a couple like
sometimes I've cried a lot on camera
because I think it I'm I'm more apt to
cry on camera actually because you're
more yourself in front of the camera I
am I really am I'm more because there's
an audience and it's not just me it's
not selfish I'm like it's for
entertainment purposes even though I'm
not doing it to entertain at least I
have the excuse of like well this just
wasn't just for you you selfish [__]
like this was at least of use to this
you know no you can totally motivate you
to dig deeper because you know you're
sharing I think that's like a human
instinct yes it's not just like I'm a
performer I think there's like good yes
yeah I but I do think crying and coming
are just so similar because I even like
I don't know how you guys are with
orgasms but I just like don't want to
have them because I know once I do
there's going to be this release and
then I'm there's not a shame like the
crying shame like but I just want I want
to hold off because it feels so good I
just don't want the good feeling to go
away before the good feeling it's always
coming you're anxiously attached to your
own orgasm yes I have yeah yeah I I
don't and then I miss them a lot of
times like I'll just hold off and then I
lose it learn multiples I Oh I thought
you said you'll miss them like oh it was
good
I really don't relate to that at all but
you can add them away I've done that
before yes that's what I've done like I
swallow them like a fart yes I did it
yesterday I was like oh my God I think I
can swallow it like a fart it's totally
and then you're someone goes yeah and
then you're like oh this was not it's
the opposite of like crying and
releasing yeah here's what I said you're
pinching off a poo and they're gonna
keep things yeah you'll never know I
know and that's the oh God you'll never
catch me holding in this now it's coming
out I don't care who's in the room
that's where Wells where's Waldo
everyone's just searching for us but I
so for me I feel like I would love to be
the kind of person that's like sexually
is just like
oh taking their time which I can and do
but the second I know I'm about to or
want to have an orgasm I'm like I will I
like almost get in a nasty bad mood I'm
like I need it now like it's kind of
gross actually no I I almost like I got
[__] to do let's get this done yeah but
how are you like I'm the same way with
food like I want to wait till I'm the
hungriest so that it tastes the best
yeah that is I want to wait for this
orgasm when I want it so bad like all
the porn I watch is like they're called
forced orgasms so they're like making
women have orgasms against their will
they're like tying women up and like
forcing them because it's a truer then
it's not my fault I Didn't Do It Like
again it's like I'm not crying it's not
me crying alone it's like this guy's
making me cry like it's not my fault I'm
not doing this like humiliating thing of
being like like or whatever you're doing
like coming is so uh embarrassing if
someone else you can blame someone for
it yeah it is you want to pass off the
responsibility now I remember for a
while you could not get yourself there
on your own am I making that up yeah no
I think that was a problem for me for a
while and how did you address that the
like suction vibrating thing oh yeah
those things no mercy and gang bangs I
just let my porn searches go a little
bit more than I want more than I felt
safe admitting like you know when you
like start to Trail off and try new
things of like you see fisting in the
corner like a little like like you'll
see like a little thing of like there's
a video professing and you go something
in your vagina like Twitches for it but
then you go I can't watch a [__]
fisting vet I'm not gonna be into
fisting I never would do that and then
then you finally go you know what oops
let me just see what this is about yeah
like I'm [__] into fist I guess that
that's what I want and so I've I let
myself indulge in those things knowing
it doesn't mean I want that yes
necessarily do you watch the show
Fleischman is in trouble no is it great
it is okay so the reason I bring it up
is because basically like my big theme
that I took away from the show was
like no matter what you choose if you
choose your career if you choose to get
married and have kids it's like when
once you're on the other side of
whatever your goal or whatever was it's
like you're still you and like nothing
changes and I obviously really relate it
to that and I'm just curious like do you
feel that way like oh I accomplished all
this [__] that like I really wanted and
like it didn't solve all my problems
like how do you speak on that totally
for me I do feel that way because I
don't really want to do anything else in
this job like I have the respect of my
peers that I care about I'm friends with
some of my heroes or whatever and then
you meet some of them you're like oh I
don't even want to be friends with these
people like I I don't want to be friend
like I have none of the drive that I
used to have like I want to be famous I
want people to know me
um maybe I want to host SNL like that's
one last goal or like but I really don't
really have that many other goals I'll
check in on you the day after you do
that right are you okay I mean I don't
really
don't you get that like when you get
asked to do something you go I have to
do this because it's like a huge
opportunity yeah I don't so much
pressure yeah well I just meant that it
would be like the your goal reached and
then the day afterwards oh
so what now that's like what I find
myself asking like what is where is the
Fulfillment coming from just friends
hangs yeah fun like being around people
that I like like not doing jobs just
because of I mean doing jobs for like
the money for sure because why not it's
like once you were at a certain level it
just gets insane and then you're like
I'm gonna be okay for life and like you
just never think that's gonna happen but
taking jobs that are fun and like
um and yeah just the hangs I like hangs
I want like fun oh my God yeah I just
want to hang out with friends and be so
like I'm figuring out where to move next
based on like who's available to hang
who doesn't have families yet who I was
like thinking about getting a house
recently and I was like maybe because
Whitney has always told me like that'll
make me feel grounded and settled if I
own is she ever giving you that speech
yeah but isn't it like also doesn't seem
so stressful owning a home is also
looking so hard and so much work yeah
stressful so I don't think it's like a a
Band-Aid or like going to solve problems
no nothing I have to say like I really
came to this discovery recently too like
laughing with friends that's like the
tippy top it is that is the best feeling
that's because it's not a drug it's not
harmful for you like it's you know I
don't know I'm also like how do we hack
our like I kind of am on this also quest
to like somehow outsmart dopamine
because it's just and like is dopamine
ruining our lives like is it like no I
think I don't think so I think you keep
going and going you have to like
you have to feel what Bliss feels like
and Chase it like force yourself into
that vibration I think you can just stay
there like what what what is your what
are you pursuing at this point in your
life you guys like what's your what like
what what are your goals inner peace
please what does that look like for you
like what are you what's something that
you wish would go away for you right now
like that anxiety anxiety about what's
in my head
anything
what is going on it's like are you uh
people are mad at me person
no I'm actually not that's good but I'm
more like longing I'm always like
longing for something in the past or
like
it's just a lot of anxiety Loops I would
say and I'm just wondering like because
when I hear anxiety and I know a lot of
times that people have anxiety they
can't put a finger on what it is is that
how it feels for you you just feel tense
or it's a specific things no no because
you know what there are things that I
have been so anxious about that took
over my life that I'm absolutely 100 now
can look back and be like oh my God that
was purely anxiety right like there was
nothing more to that there was no truth
behind that right and so now and then it
always moves on to something else so
similar to depression because depression
there's no truth behind anythings I'm
saying when I'm depressed of like you're
not talented you're ugly you've tricked
everyone everyone's you're aging you're
old you're fat whatever it's like oh you
don't want dreams I go to find truth
a couple in there all right to YouTube
you can find them oh yeah oh yeah but
it's something someone that will give it
to you no you're right you're right and
but it's But anxiety is it's lying to
you you get caught in a loop of like
this yeah and then the other thing that
[__] with me is like I'm reading all
this like self-help and like science on
the subjects and stuff and I'm like I'm
aware I'm literally aware that the
things I think are just anxiety Loops I
know but that doesn't fix it it doesn't
fix it to even know that like I'm I'm
dating these guys because my dad did
this thing right wish that would lift it
like that that's the [__] up thing
about therapy you get in you figure out
why you are the way you are and it
doesn't fix it to know it almost gets it
just keeps getting worse the more you
know the worse it is because you know
how bad it is and you can't fix it it's
it's like I don't know why I'm so used
to this concept that like once I know
the problem the problem is gone but
that's not true the other day I thought
I had a friend that like thought I was
mad at her and I was just so mad because
I was like then I was mad at her because
I'm like why why would I be mad at you
yeah like do you I always tell my
friends Ian Finance is always like
calling me back after we hang up like
was that weird are you mad at me I'm
like oh my gosh I've never once been mad
at you Ian literally never you you're so
pleasant you are so like respectful
about are you someone that has that is
he triggering like a part of you that
you have with other people do you have a
thing where you think people are mad at
you never no no I don't have that either
I I really get boggled what I get I feel
like people don't know me when they
think I'm mad at them I'm like you think
I'd get mad at you about what that said
something weird yeah I think they can
explain that because I think that's just
people who have anxious attachments in
that relationship this was something
Whitney actually pointed out to me that
was so helpful because I was having an
anxious attachment with someone and she
was kind of giving me advice about it
and she was like look at your
relationship with me she's like if if
you call me and I don't answer do you
are you concerned I'm like no not at all
I know I'll see you we'll talk she's
like so you have a secure attachment
with me right and I was like oh like I
loved knowing what that felt like and I
realized I don't know I guess you're not
the one with the issue but no but I
definitely have insecure attachments
like my relationship I realized I put
way too much stock in it has way too
much of a hold over me like he's someone
that needs to process if we get into a
fight and we make up and everything's
fine like he understands my point I
understand his point we understand what
we're gonna do in the future he still
needs time to like get over the hurt and
maybe like be alone a little better like
maybe that's so annoying when you're
anxious because they're like
let's deal with it bury it yeah I can't
I can't be and then I wanna and then I
want to leave because I just want to not
be around him when he's processing but
then it triggers his abandonment stuff
if I leave so I have to like kind of
stay it's this weird dance but I realize
that so much of my depression is
dependent on like if my relationship is
feeling if I'm feeling like seen and
loved enough but then when I'm single I
don't I'm like what is what triggers my
depression when I'm single I don't even
know I guess if a guy I like is texting
me but it's like a lot of that [__] oh I
was so anxious when I was single right
oh my God
I kind of like fed off of me yeah like I
liked the excitement of like Willie text
back oh I just texted this really bold
thing that really hit it like did you go
to like all your guy friends was this
crazy that I just texted this totally
yeah I like never talked to my guy
friends on the boyfriend and it's not
because it's like because I'm like what
am I gonna call them I don't need advice
I was in school today it's so true
that's what they were there for yeah but
Todd's really securely attached I was
talking about that last night where it's
hard when you I think put your career
first and you're like not even I like
was not focused on having a relationship
even though I was dating and stuff and
still getting all [__] up over guys I
was busy I was like I don't want a
relationship I want to focus on this and
then I got to a point where I was like
okay I should probably get a
relationship you know I'm in my late 30s
and then I was like oh wait all this
securely I'm anxiously attached so I
either need to somehow cure the way I am
or I need to find a securely attached
guy but all of them are [__] married
because they're security
and I'm like anyone that's older than me
is and not has never been married is
[__] you gotta go wrong so then I
went younger I smashed caught up before
yes because your security your
relationship's secure security he is
secure so I came into this relationship
extremely anxious there was just never
ever going to be another option for me
um and then I have become secure so
that's what they say it can like that
calms you down that's what's amazing is
yeah however I struggle with so I
recently realized that my emotional
needs were not met as a child and I
think that is a big problem but so we've
been talking about like okay I need
again I think having a secure person
that you can communicate your needs to
is huge and I think it sounds like
that's what you guys are doing like if
you know he needs space after first
that's annoying but it's like yes like
yeah I know that he'll get over it
eventually I have to like tell myself
that yeah because in my mind I'm like
we've decided get over it and I'm not
gonna be with someone who's like this
the rest of my life [__] this I want to
cut and run like I want to like I want
to [__] jump off the balcony
interesting because he did
do everything you wanted to be like yeah
you know that's that's the question
where I go should I be with someone who
doesn't process things like this because
it is such a trigger for me where it
used to be the point where he would when
he was much more immature and like
didn't do work on himself he would
punish me with silence for like which is
a really long time and it was brutal and
I just took it because I and he didn't
respect me and I didn't really respect
him because I just wanted a boyfriend
and was like lying about who I was to
like fit the mold of the woman he wanted
and
um and then he found out I was lying and
then he was I mean it was so
dysfunctional but I told him in our
relationship now after we've broken up a
lot and like done a lot of work and
gotten back together I'm like if if that
ever happened again it's the same as if
you hit me like I can't it's it would be
worse to me than than and but because he
knows what he's doing he knows how much
that would hurt you exactly he doesn't
do it anymore now because he know like I
can tell him like I can see that he
wants to go there and just punish me
with silence because that's his go-to
right benefit or something right I don't
fault him for it and that's where we get
mixed up because
he will be like I go I don't judge you
for this being your thing like I I don't
hate you like sometimes I do hate you
for it but I can look at it and go oh
this is your this is just the way you
are because of how you were raised like
I can I think that sometimes if you
haven't done enough work on yourself you
can't there's so much blame being placed
and couples are always like well it
seems like you're putting all the blame
on me and I'm like it's like I'm
avoiding the blame on you I'm just
saying you do this thing that triggers
me and you do this thing it's not your
fault it's your parents fault they are
totally it was false that is also it's
like I could heal this part of me but
it's gonna be really hard if you keep
poking it at me and stuff well that's
like a true trauma Bond it's like that
at that point what you're saying in the
like previous iteration of your
relationship was like your trauma up
against his trauma like and it it's
that's a tell and the fact that now like
you're communicating that to me is so
like honestly beautiful like the fact
that
like does it help you that you know that
after a fight he needs a beat like are
you able to have a secure attachment
because you know that's what he needs
I'm getting there yeah like that's what
I'm doing in therapy now is like instead
of going to the place of like we're not
meant to be I can't this per he's better
suited for a girl that would just be
like oh Chris is in one of his moods
like some women just like oh John you
know how he gets and like doesn't make
it personally doesn't want to like cut
themselves because their boyfriend's
ignoring them that's where I go to where
I'm like what like I don't cut myself
but I'm like I've start to think about
what could I do my friend was like told
me the other day that she like because
she does self-harm and she's like I'm
out of places to cut but I've been
hitting my head with my hair dryer and I
was like don't tell me that because
that's a really good one like that's
where I want to do that [__] when I get
ignored by my boyfriend it goes right to
that so oh that means you're like mad at
yourself right yeah I feel like he hates
me when he's ignoring me I feel like
he's just like disgusted with me which
is already what I think of myself and I
have this shame of like being just dirty
and like not as good as other women or
whatever and then I want to just hurt my
yeah I want to hurt myself self and so
I'm like when if you ignore me I'll hurt
myself you will relate to this story so
much very early on I mean Dave's
relationship we were at a restaurant we
got into a fight of course there's some
dumb thing that I probably picked a
fight about I was so mad I left I got up
I left I went walked back to our place
and then I called my friend and was like
let's go walk the reservoir because I
was like in my head I'm like I'm running
away from home I was like he's gonna
leave the restaurant he's gonna come
home and see that I'm not there and have
no idea where I am and he's gonna freak
out right so we go I walk through
Reservoir with my friend the whole time
I'm like you know like trying to pretend
like I'm having fun but I'm like huffing
and puffing just thinking about like how
he's gonna be so worried about me I come
home my big dramatic entrance like you
know like he's asleep on the couch
yeah yeah he didn't care he didn't even
notice I was like
oh
do you know what the cops were gonna be
there
yes thank you you should have left like
a blood trailer yes
foreign
have you ever been stewing about a
health problem you have and you almost
resort to texting your group chat to get
your friends opinions but then you're
like wait that's like not I'm not that's
not gonna work okay you're extremely
unlikely to find quality medical advice
in your group chat I'm just taking a
wild guess here but you can actually
find it from a doctor on ZocDoc there
are thousands of medical professionals
on ZocDoc there to help you they listen
like a friend and they give you the
expert care that you need side note it's
also so annoying when you get to a
doctor's appointment and they're in a
freaking Rush it's like I already drove
I parked I waited and now you're rushing
me out of here no that's why ZocDoc is a
true essential in my life because I need
someone that has good reviews that has a
good bedside manner that's not going to
be rude and rush me like this is my time
to shine like give me my time
and on ZocDoc you'll find quality
doctors who focus on you and listen to
you and prioritize your care ZocDoc is
the only free app that lets you find and
book doctors who are patient reviewed
take your insurance are available when
you need them and treat almost every
condition Under the Sun go to zocdoc.com
trash and download the ZocDoc app for
free then find in book a top-rated
doctor today many are available within
24 hours that's
zocdoc.com trash
oh
we were at a concert and it was like a
pain in the ass together graphic it was
um Adam Sandler actually oh I called the
concert because it was the best show
which by the way cultivating the Hang
Adam Sandler nailed it only work with
fun and friends
he's the king he's the coolest and his
show was incredible and uh his special
100 fresh if I want to cry I listen to
that Farley song and like that's my porn
Christ thing that I put on but we were
at that and he had had a long day of
work things had happened throughout the
day like he told me later on little
indignities throughout the day and he
was just in a bad mood and then when we
were on the way there I like he had he
knew the directions and I like took over
and it was just one more and it kind of
like he was just not in the mood and so
I go what's going on like are you we
finally said I go what's going on he
just goes I just had a really rough day
okay I just had a really bad day and I
go and instead of being like I'm sorry
but but he was already giving me a
little bit like he wasn't he's walking
ahead like I tried to like hold his hand
he just kind of squeezed it and like was
like and just little like he couldn't
didn't I get it like sometimes you just
can't get there for the person that like
needs it so much he's trying his best
but I said to him I go well then I
should be a comfort for you when you're
having a bad day like don't
take it out on me and I think that got
through to him because I just said that
I go well then on days like this I
should be comfort for you not someone
that you just pile it onto and take it
out on like I'm there to hear about your
bad day and like make you like snuggle
you and make you feel better and I just
like was like you know what I wanted to
leave but I also was like I want to see
Adam Sandler so I wanted to like put my
foot down and do the Uber thing but
instead I was like actually next time I
might leave in an Uber yeah he thinks I
might not uh if it was yeah the last
show we went to yeah it was um so I I
stayed and I just decided to have a good
time and I like completely was present
and was able to like laugh and not be
like thinking about it which is a secure
moment for you right where it's not like
circumstantial to whether he's making
you happier yeah and it was helpful that
my friend was with me like my friend was
in town so I was able to focus I because
otherwise we would have been on a double
date and I would have been like just but
I was able to just like take care of my
friend have fun with her and then I made
some mention to him about like the
lighting or something I was like oh and
just some just to like reach out a
little bit and as soon as I did he was
like I'm sorry and it was just the
producer so yeah
[Applause]
we was he able to receive your comfort
yes and as soon as because he goes I'm
sorry and then the second he did that I
go babe I'm so sorry you had a bad day
and I'm like kissing his neck and like
just and that's all I want to do like I
love I'm never gonna be a mom but I have
maternal things like I like comforting
boys when they're like my favorite
version of him is when he's like a widow
baby he's just like I like that I'm not
gonna cry though too but you know what
it is it seems like with your like your
first iteration of your relationship or
what however many people did that like
that first phase was like you guys were
like against yes fighting against each
other which I think is normal and really
oh it's impossible not you date like who
you the the lesson you need to learn
because yeah yeah but then but then
coming back and I think Esther you guys
didn't break up but I think you guys
probably went through this too even
though you weren't against each other
but you like maybe more against yourself
yes like we had a lot of I mean I have I
had a lot of growing up right necessary
well he was a grown-up yes compared yes
like we look back a lot and he even gets
mad when it's like I'll I'll be like how
did you not break up with me like it's
weird he's like I know
when I stood you up there and I I yelled
at you there and I I cried over oysters
here yeah no it's like yeah it's that's
why but I love hearing about this
because I do really believe that it's
it's an with so many of us think it's
about that magic spark that connection
that oh God yeah it's not about that
it's about being with someone that is
willing to be vulnerable about their
triggers and what they need and like and
when you want like you said harder for
men I really like I I empathize and like
not all of them not yeah not all of them
but and it's hard for someone like it's
hard for me but for sure we have just I
I think it's healthy to talk about these
things when you're not in it like when
you like like hey you know when we get
into these things I read this thing
today that might help us when we get
into that again like because I think we
never talked about our fights they would
happen we'd resolve them and then we
there was no mention of them until they
happened again and then I feel like but
what I was gonna say was like your thing
with the the second round is like you
guys are are working together and for
you to be able to say to him like I
should be able to comfort you yeah and
him to be able to receive that is so
sweet and I think that that took balls
for me to say because I feel like in the
past he would have just been like like
wouldn't have liked my tone being like
well I'm not putting up with it like I
should be there to comfort you done and
it's like I was always just like
whatever you want like walk all over me
which is not what he wanted at all but
now I say a good another good if if
anyone's listening that has a boyfriend
like this or maybe you're like this and
your boyfriend is anxiously attached
whenever we get whenever he shuts down
and like needs to process and is kind of
like shutting me out because it's his
go-to it doesn't mean he's a bad person
I just say all I need you to do is like
Touch My Le like touch my leg or like
give me a sign that will be okay because
my mind is you're gonna break up with me
and I'm never gonna see you again so
when you get like I say something that
maybe like you know when you're a mixed
company and I'll share something he goes
I never said that and I go Oh I thought
you did he's like no and then I've sense
like oh the Wall's up he's annoyed with
me he's kind of like grossed out that I
would even say that mixed company this
private thing we said and I got it wrong
he thinks I'm a liar and I go he hates
me he's gonna break up with me so now
he'll just under the table even though
he's upset and we're going to talk about
it later he'll just put his hand on my
legs do a little bit
foreign
[Music]
of things where it's like oh I am
absolutely horrible and he doesn't like
me as a person at all he just wants to
[__] me like that he always is like
absolutely not but that is a place I go
to where I'm like just say it well also
yeah no also it's like when you get old
enough to just be like I'm gonna just
ask for the exact compliment that I want
then I have a 50 50 chance of getting it
like doesn't my ass look great she's
either gonna make a joke or say yes
like I'm not I'm not like waiting around
to try to like Voodoo mind it's like can
I mind trick someone and they can't come
up with what they they can't read your
mind you really do have to be that
that's another huge one I literally had
to ask just write me a list and he was
like I was thinking that might be a good
idea and I go then fine it was your idea
but I yeah it doesn't take away from it
if I tell you what to do when you do it
that means a lot to me oh how
infuriating if that really was what his
present was I know oh well you can tell
it was real yeah like yeah he was like I
swear that was gonna be one a part of
the gift and then he got me a workbook
for the Sue Johnson woman and got us
both each the book we haven't done it
yet but it was just like okay say
something that when you brought the
thing up therapist I I don't know about
these headshots oh no no do I need my
therapist to have a professional
headshot no it's so it's you got a hair
and makeup for my
I think I disagree I think like you want
to put a face yeah but you want it look
if you want to see that guy is that
ideal no God
just you think like I like him but think
of like what like what what does
motivation in that picture do you guys
think I'm gonna keep these couples
together yeah do you see them like every
week I don't see mine every week I I
would say I go more through like a
couple months on a couple months off but
I would I I need to every week I'm what
do they do what kind of like what do
they do what do you like about them
um
I just talk because I feel like I do I'm
like did I just do a podcast like a solo
pot like a Mark Maron yeah I need some
interaction for sure like I definitely
don't like when I'm just speaking like I
need guidance right and like you know
stuff like that boundaries is what I
because I will friend up real fast
you'll friend oh I'll friend up well
it's like okay so I have a
hypnotherapist oh yeah that's right
she's my friend yeah so then I'll be on
the phone with her like a friend and
then she gets into therapy voice and
then I'm like oh God I like switched her
into therapist mode and then yeah so
it's not like and then are you on the
like
yeah yeah sorry [__] that's so
interesting
um yeah I do hypnotherapy I don't have a
traditional therapist but I do
hypnotherapy and then I do breath work
sessions with my xiaomi ah a little sham
yeah have you ever done like one-on-one
yeah yeah since I was a kid are you not
into it I mean not right now I like the
stuff that I'm doing what does
hypnotherapy do for you it's like a
session where you like go through some
of the issues that you're having that
week and you like discuss
what your beliefs are that are like
triggering you so if I'm mad at
let's see if I'm annoyed that my agent
is booking me five shows instead of four
or something I'm like I already told him
that so it's like basically what that's
getting down to is like feeling unheard
and then it's like so what is what's the
what would my brain need to feel to like
and then what's the belief about myself
like I'm someone that doesn't deserve to
be heard no one ever listens to me
people are against me that's great so
then what's the opposite thing that I
need to hear which is like everyone like
I'm on my own side I take care of myself
I believe in myself I speak strongly the
things that I need stuff like that yeah
and then and then they'll write up a
hypnosis to listen to
that's cool see that seems like there's
action being taken and I like I like
when my therapist gives me some home
because we've had it there we've all had
the therapist I think that I've had
therapists where it felt like a lot of
the kicking up the dirt
and then none of the like how do we now
sweep you know what people who might be
listening to this don't kick up the dirt
like we do on a normal basis yeah we are
such open books that we I go into
therapy and I go and they'll go thank
you so much for sharing that and I go I
just got I was just live on air saying
that yeah another podcast like this
isn't intimate to me you can tell other
clients like I don't care yeah she's
like do you want to enter a back to
entry you can use my headshot yeah
I like I I think that we there there is
benefit for that because some people are
just so stuffed up with their they've
never even said a lot like I remember my
boyfriend the first time he went to
therapy he said
it's weird saying like things out loud
for like that you've only ever thought
like you've never said them out loud and
I'm like you've You've Won I know I've
never said a lot it's weird when I don't
say a thought out loud like sometimes I
try I'm like what if I just keep this to
myself well I had vocal cord surgery and
that blew my mind because I had to be
quiet for three weeks not a single Peep
and it was brutal and what I learned
from it is that to to say something I
would have to type it in my phone and
then this little robot I post press the
thing it would read it and it just made
me do you like Kevin Hart's voice you
know you can do that on a ways oh yeah
it's like Santa
and so I uh it made you realize it made
me realize that like when I would have a
thought and go oh I want to express this
instead of it just being like do like
out like I don't think of like the
things I say they are thoughts first
intention even right now intention yeah
even right now as I'm talking I've
thought this a microsecond before I said
it yeah it's starting here but it
doesn't feel like it feels like it just
starts here but when you have no this it
all is here and then you have to go
is this important like is this enough
for me to take out my phone and like
write it and say so so often first of
all I realize I'm way funnier than I
thought because I just thought like
Annie you're so quick like it's like I
sometimes get depressed doing this
podcast because I'm just like God
there's another and another and another
and that's what I'm here for to make you
feel better no you are too I was trying
to say or hi to give you an out no
no like we know
like start to make me feel like God what
I'm a fraud or whatever but I think that
being quiet made me realize like I'm
thinking of funny [__] all the time and
so many times you just don't say it
because it's so about time as you know
like if you miss a second then it's not
worth saying sorry about the
interrupting yeah we're sorry you're I
mean you're someone who takes more
chances saying like throwing things up I
don't care if it and that's why you're
probably better at it because you don't
you're not worried like is this maybe
not gonna you need the balls to like
throw I'll just say I've done my ten
thousand
but you have to get through that to get
to the the side that you are now which
is just like one of the the quickest in
the game and but I found that it's just
so interesting to to process it first
and go and so many times I avoided
conflict just by being like
instead of just saying it as I would or
calling something out I would think
about it before I didn't go uh it's not
like I didn't do it in time when it
passed so many when it passes and you go
oh my God I was literally about to send
that text I mean yeah
when it passes and you go like oh
my God one of my favorite Warren Buffett
quotes is you can always I'm gonna do
your favorites how many do you have
we're finding out new things
um is you can always tell someone to go
to hell tomorrow
and like that is like so whenever I
think oh that's bad I'm like that is
something you would say when you're mad
go to hell tomorrow
that's really funny and so we're like if
you are finding yourself wanting to like
be mad at someone like I'm always like
just see how you feel tomorrow usually
it's something you're it's like just
triggering your own yeah I feel like
once has it have you ever have I ever
been mad at someone and then I waited
and then instead of I do the opposite
and like meet him with kindness and go
you know what I could have been cool and
then it completely like everything's
smooth after that yeah I'm so sorry it's
never once escalated if I just take the
high road and don't don't get dirty but
it's so fun to [__] well it's like
yeah one of the one of the guys who
whose podcast that you're supposed to
listen to he always said um
don't get in the water like if people
want to get wet they can get wet but
don't get in the water with them so when
people come at you I mean that is so
[__] hard because I'm Philly like
when people come at me like I want to be
like oh really like yeah you think that
was bad do you want to see oh I actually
wasn't doing that I could do it though
yes oh like if I feel falsely accused of
something I'm like oh I can show you
what could go down but it's like to not
do it it's just so much better and then
you're just not in the thing I go with
Taylor Swift let this derail her day oh
I love that and she's put in my mind she
would write a song about it yeah and she
would make up [__] grammy-winning
album out of it but like the other day
my friend was like thought I was mad at
her and then I go why would I be mad at
you when I was like texting my friends
about like my friend thinks she's why
would she think I'm mad at her like why
would she think I purposely left her all
and it was like and I was gonna have to
go on podcast stuff and then your poor
friends are like oh my God and so I just
and then I just snapped out and I was
like would a successful person who was
like a would a CEO let this derail the
rest of their day and affect every
meeting they go into and it was like No
And then it just went away yeah and it
was really gone after I did that and I
was just act as if you're Taylor Swift
that is such a good exercise I I who
would you act as if yeah I don't know
but I wanna maybe Lana I was thinking
though like literally eight years ago I
remember I was like having some kind of
personal drama whatever whatever it was
and Duncan Trussell I would like always
go to him for advice and he was like you
need to think of yourself as Miley Cyrus
yeah and in that moment I definitely was
like laughed at him and was like what is
he saying and now years later of course
of course his wisdom was so it was too
wise I feel bad for Duncan when I'm
around he is like I am like get ready to
back into a corner energies no no no no
not opposite exactly no I just I'm like
I see him and I'm like it's on [__]
like I'm like sorry everybody I'm taking
Duncan he's so awesome I'm like yeah oh
my God he's everything that's great and
he remembers everything he's ever
learned he has so much knowledge in his
head about all the spiritual stuff his
mom and he studied with ram Das and
stuff he's real oh yeah yeah yeah I got
him I gotta hang out with him but it's
so good to act like someone else that's
what I did in comedy like when you start
out I would just I think that I always
tell young Comics like they're like how
do I what jokes do I write I go right
right as if you're writing for your
favorite comic because your favorite
comic you probably like because they're
kind of like well you can always tell
someone's favorite comic when they first
start always and I love hey little girl
Jeselnik no one ever sounds like me and
I'm insulted I see so many like
Whitney's out there I see so many like
paper lands a lot of kids
doing me and I'm like come on let's see
some I don't think that's true well I'd
like to see some examples but yeah um
but yeah but it's that's act as if and
then but that's whatever that's the way
through is like if you're struggling
you know what it is it's like okay so in
all manifesting it's always like you
want to like be the thing first to get
it you know which seems like such a mind
[__] because you're like how can I be
this thing I don't have so it helps if
you ha if you can imagine yourself as
someone else study someone that has the
things that you would like or you admire
like when I was struggling with money I
would just watch all these Lady Gaga
interviews because Lady Gaga Just she'll
go she'll say things like she has no
shame in her like Fame and start I'm
like she'll be like I should I saw some
interview where she was like looking
over like old pictures she goes oh I
already knew I was a star here here to
me like back in the day that would have
been gross right you know what I mean
and because I thought those things were
gross I was never gonna get the things
that I wanted you know there was like
Facebook groups that girls made about
hers that Stephanie germanana will never
be famous it's like still an active
Facebook group that they made in like
high school about her because she was so
like I'm gonna be famous someday and so
adamant about it Kim Kardashian also
knew she was gonna be famous I knew too
and I to tell my friends that and they
like Kim Kardashian
like there's this girl that's cleaning
person's closet you're not even gonna
believe Jay and his lawyer but I have a
hot daughter and the other one
when I was little I had like feelings
about like being in front of the camera
and stuff but I was so embarrassed by
them it took so long for me to really
like Blossom out there's yeah there's no
comedy like classes as a kid yeah well
there are and there are now and it's
yeah we're teaching them but you guys it
also feels like that is it makes so much
sense for comedians to because it's like
you have to be
people are so in touch with their flaws
and what's wrong with them that of
course all of us are like no no you know
it that's like a complicated
relationship then you're like yeah am I
gonna be like working for sandwiches am
I going to be performing oh a sandwich
for the rest of my life I just knew and
but I didn't know how that's the
frustrating thing I was not a good
singer I wasn't a good actress I did
couldn't dance couldn't play an
instrument I go what the [__] am I gonna
and then reality TV came out and I go
well I don't want to I knew I could
probably get on real world because I was
like I'll probably be good at this but
then I knew that people would say you're
not famous for this thing I'd be not
famous for anything they approached me
of course they approached me I was in
Santa Fe and all the producers they were
the real world challenge I'd throw up on
everyone got wasted that was my fear too
of like I need to get I vomited all over
them but they don't want you sober no
and then so we were all like on one of
the off hours they were like sitting
down and the producers were like so tell
us your story and I was like I'm out
I was like I got bigger plans yeah no
offense to my railroad Road Rose people
no well now you know we you can parlay
it and like people forget that you were
ever on it Christine positski Theo one
like people are like what they were on
those shows yeah it's a total blip but
at the time it felt like oh I don't want
to be famous that way so uh but I
remember like telling my I was in love
with Dave Matthews in high school and I
remember telling my friend holla like
um I'm gonna meet him someday like I'm
go and they were just like my friend's
just being disgusted like you think
you're gonna meet him and I was like
yeah they're like you're not gonna and I
go not like in a contest either like I'm
gonna be I'm not gonna wait in line for
it famous too and I'm gonna be in the
same sphere and so when I met him I said
the word sphere a lot because I was like
telling the story and it was so it was
so it was so embarrassing when I met him
finally because I was like I knew I'd be
in the same sphere and it was just like
he didn't even know who I was it was so
it was just like I can't even get over
it but um yeah like I think yeah
humiliated though it's funny like
because this is cringe to be talking
about but it's like it is so CR like to
want to be famous and of course now I
don't my dream was always like to be in
a restaurant and have people going like
that would be amazing now it has
happened before it does not get me off
like I would think it would it doesn't I
don't care I don't care but it's nice to
know and I know that people go like
uh that that famous people or people
that have reached success always go
that's not what makes you happy yeah and
people are like that's not what we it's
so crazy I literally never bring up
Duncan and he's coming up twice yeah
episode I also remember when I first met
Dave I was telling Duncan like yeah like
I'm in love now and I don't really give
a [__] about stand up and he was like
that's because we all got into this
because we just wanted love and of
course I was too dumb to like understand
it it stuck with me thankfully but I was
like what I was like what no but that
backfired on me because I had boyfriends
that would like get jealous of like that
I didn't give them that much because I'm
like but I'm like what you think I need
from you I get from like a room full of
you yeah like I don't need the same
amount of things oh see I don't think a
girl would need not like that at all
literally the first two weeks of dating
Dave I was like so I think I'm quitting
stand up get what you're saying and then
like later that night he was like I
think it's really weird that you want to
quit the thing that you do and I had to
be like oh yeah I didn't mean it no but
it you're right it is we're searching
for that's anything that's why it tends
to not have low self-esteem and to not
be craving love is so in denial well
also because it that then you're not
good because that's why we do this why
would you want strangers to laugh at you
and give you validation every couple
seconds no if you liked yourself like
and the reason that you said oh I wanted
to be to walk into a restaurant and have
people go is that Nikki Glazer because
you wanted to feel love and scene and
then now that you have that it's you're
like
well that's not and what I do when now
when they do it I go well they only like
me because I had full hair and makeup
and because I had written those lines
before and I I all they don't know the
preparation that's not naturally me and
then that's where I get upset when like
someone's like fire emojis under a
picture of me that's like I'm spray
tanned and fake hair and everything I go
now they don't even like me
um did you see Pam Anderson's
documentary and her talking about the
rose and how she did it for PETA like
she wouldn't have like she that only
added to the cultural narrative about
her being a [__] and like disposal and
all the things like she took that hit
for Animals I just love her so much she
took that head constantly constantly
that was all we knew her as like a
laughing stock and what a sweet person
she was and like
um the other thing that I see that she's
doing that is like low-key such a huge
deal that you wouldn't necessarily think
but in my mind it's a big deal is that I
see her going around and doing
interviews talking about like how porn
is is not good for people which I I use
porn I like it I watch it but I think
that because she gets like men listen to
her the fact that she's using her
platform which is like to people that
are probably into that kind of stuff and
like saying what's bad about it not
saying like oh it can yeah but I just
feel like she really does want the world
to be a better place like she does it's
it's so sweet it's a sweet sweet person
but she I haven't heard her talk out
against porn and I struggle with it
though because I love it so much and I
feel like I have a sometimes unhealthy
relationship like I I like it you know I
go it's I like I only watch gang bangs
like I didn't start that way and like is
it leads into gangbang store now yeah
yeah Lisa and I like the same kind of
stuff like we're but it's just like I
know where this heads it's like it's it
gets more and more extreme and then
there becomes victimization like I know
I've watched girls do things they don't
want to do I know I have there has to in
the thousands of videos I've watched
there's been a girl that's like I hate
this I was coerced this is not what I
signed up for but I can't say no right
now because there's a bunch of guys here
and I really want this production
company to keep using me and I need
money to pay my rent like I know I've
watched that and aided it should have
seen our first live
well I will say
I actually think the bigger issue in
porn is not the filming of it itself but
I'm sure that that I know that's also a
problem but like okay it's men watching
it and then thinking that that's the way
and not being able to get off from
regular sex and having like to choke
women oh my God and then have you ever
had sex with so wait my point was that
it's okay that we watch it okay but have
you ever had sex with a guy who tries to
porn star you it's so boring I don't
know you might like it I don't like it
when they're like oh like you can just
tell they are like mimicking yes when
you Bang actors yeah actors I feel like
are doing a role it's like are we
[__] role playing yes yes
everyone be a firefighter I don't think
there's anyone who's gonna be having sex
for the first time a young man in
college like who's not going where else
would you get where else would you see
sex taking place and learn how to act
like it used to be just before porn you
figure it out like on people's bodies
that's yeah it's so cute yeah but it's
not though that's also not good but of
course you're gonna like what do I do
with them to something to go what do I
do and where else is there to show you
normal sex I mean movies don't give you
my parents had full pen my you want to
see that you want to see how it's like
Penitentiary yeah
um
my parents had the they like ordered off
the back of the Playboy the like better
sex
videos do you remember seeing those oh
so like instructional videos but it was
like you know everyone had like no
offense but you know when you're a kid
and like the girl's short hair and
you're like
okay mom like
so there are things but like if you had
kids that were teenagers about to have
sex what would you
and you knew your son's watching like
what do you do do you thinking of a
child sexual slimers like this is not
what it is but I think it is what it is
now I think people have sex like that I
also just have to assume that like
Society will somehow solve this like
before I have a teenage child right like
yeah why does it feel like it would come
out a teenager
wearing your outfits oh my I'll be so
happy do you ever like hold on to
clothes that you're like I want to give
this to my dog I think about it I'm so
mad at some of the shirts I see my in my
mom I've never felt like that I want
that [__] I think about it but you
know what it's like maybe t-shirts but
things come back but they're never like
quite the same and they're always a
little bit like shaped a little
differently it's not showing like the
ass or like everything's so cheaply made
now that like back in the 70s like
people like made clothes and now like
children and machines make them my in
this I think probably in the 70s or 80s
my mom lived in Tulsa Oklahoma and she
worked for the Tulsa cable company and I
think she was like a receptionist and
she had these HBO shorts like that they
gave to people who sold and I'm like
were they like umbros no no they were
just like material yeah like just cool
little comfy HBO shorts and I'm like
I'll never have those well you can get
Lucy guys
um you guys thank you so much for
listening go see Nikki live go see all
of us live and we'll see you next week
with a brand new episode
[Music]
foreign